Interoperability remains a major
technical issue because of
the multiplicity of EMRs
in use here in the US.
There are hundreds of certified EMRs and
although a dozen or so
represent 75% of all installations,
the rest are spread among many vendors.
As you can see from this graphic
from the ONC's dashboard,
a place I recommend you visit.
These systems were not designed to
record data in a standard fashion or
to share data with other systems.
They are not interoperable.
EHR certification creates a very
minimal degree of interoperability.
As we'll see later on,
building technologies to facilitate
more extensive data sharing among
these systems is a major focus
of contemporary health IT.